hello everyone I do hope you're having
an excellent Sunday because we have an
amazing game from the penultimate round
of the 2018 isle of man chess tournament
I'm sure you've all heard of the German
Bobby Fischer the 13-year old Vincent
gamer not sure if his 13 year old
anymore the last time I did a video on
him he was 13 years old and I will put a
link to that video in the description
below as well if you want to check it
out and to learn something more about
him
that that was from the grand K chess
Festival where he won the the open
section of the Greenwich s Festival this
year in 2018 with an astonishing 8 out
of 9 points beating Richard report in
the final round the link in description
below I will lead you to that game where
Vincent played against Richard rapid in
green K open chess tournament but this
game it's from like we said I am chess
and he faces the legend Boris Gelfand
now we do have one nice photo of this
encounter there you have it it's a photo
by John Saunders he's taking a lot of
photos of this event he's the official
photographer I will also put a link to
his his own profile so you can check out
some of some more of the photos from
this tournament and it's hard to say
what the hedge fund is doing it's as if
he's sleeping but I don't think that's
the case but you know it did happen if
you remember Magnus Carlsen fell asleep
a beat a bit during his game against
with Manhattan Island that one time but
okay without further ado let's check out
this very nice game and I always say
without further ado and then I want to
say something more but usually when
there is a great game played I will
receive a lot of messages on different
social platforms and for this game I
received a lot a lot of messages so I
knew that it was going to be a great
game but only after I have seen it I
knew that it indeed is an excellent game
but ok now really without further ado
Vincent opens with d4 so not afraid of
any alliance Boris is ready to throw at
him he is open to a great fight nice to
have sex by Gelfand we have
c4 e6 a knight to a3 and of course d5 we
entered a Queens gambit
we have Knight to c3
we have c 6 e 3 and 15 I'd be 37 so this
is now the main line of the semi Slav
Queen to c2 we have a Bishop to d6
Bishop to d3 would have castles castles
and rook to e8 so this has all been
played before we have E for now pawn
captures on c4 Bishop captures on c4 and
e5 now we have looked at e1 and here
interestingly in 1997
Karpov had this exact same position
against the last event you can
Montecarlo were event to continued with
Queen to e7 and the Dead game were ended
ended in a draw but here gelfand has a
different idea he plays he captures on
d4 and already on move 11 we have a game
that was never played before so this
position is not available in any
database so any move from now is a
straight you know that comes out of
creativity out of calculation out of not
out of preparation Knight captures and
before by Gelfand sorry back gamer you
don't want to capture with the rook as
this rook would really feel silly on d4
so Knight captures on d4 the night is
much better here on a nice central
square I would have Queen to c7 get on
now that develops the Queen while also
attacking the H to pawn and here g3 it's
interesting h3 seems like a better move
as it's a move for example I would
probably play perhaps not if I
immediately had to if I thought about
the move but seems like it does the same
job and also prevents this knife from
ever ever jumping to g4 but that's why I
Vincent is an international master and I
am NOT he places his all of his pawns on
a dark square and this Bishop will now
be able to cover all of the pawns via
the light squares Knight to e5 attacking
the bishop on c4 and now Bishop back to
e2
controlling this knight on e5 and also
perhaps at some point f4 will be a
possibility
Bishop to h3 get one now takes away the
light squares away from the White King
has now this formation with the dark
squares allows this move and it seems
that all of the elephants pieces are an
excellent squares the bishop is really
an amazing piece and h3 add the rook
will at some point come to d8 and blacks
position is definite
we great Bishop to g5 and now Knight eg4
also guarding the knight on f6 so now
you will not have to capture with the
pawn if Bishop captures on f6 is played
yeah but by playing Knight to g4 the
bishop on h3 doesn't really have all
that many squares so here Vincent
simply attacks it forces a trade we have
Bishop captures rook captures and now
Bishop to e5 makes room for this rook to
enter the game also comes up with an
attack against the undefended knight on
d5 Vincent goes Knight to a5 and now
even g6 get funded doesn't mind
awakening his King side position a bit
as he does have a dark square Bishop
which we can use to cover the dark
squares I've forgot to mention at the
profile photo of gate frontier on the
left is also by John Saunders the
photographer whose photo we've already
seen we have Knight to h6 check Knight
captures Bishop captures and now Knight
to g4 attacking the bishop on h6 bishop
the back to d2 and now finally rook a to
d8 get fund fully mobilizes all of his
pieces and his position is quite
excellent King to g2 a very nice move by
Vincent as f4 seems like move you want
to play but it would be a bit too hasty
because for example Queen b6 check you
have to do something about this King to
h1 and now Bishop captures on c3
for example B captures on c3 and the now
comes Knights the e3 attacking the Queen
and the rook you have to capture Queen
Bishop kafirs Queen captures and now the
rook is coming to d2 after a rook F e1
attacking the Queen you will simply
attack the Queen and now after captures
captures it will be a much better
endgame for black with the two the week
C over C and the week a pawn black
should be able to win this game and
perhaps it's not straight you know
winning but I guess found this confident
in his abilities to push it for a win
against a young Vincent
so first King to g2 by Vincent and then
now comes Queen to e7
we have h3 kicking away the knight
Knight to f6 and the now comes the rook
F
one point to c5 now here a good fund
that wants to move the Queen as you
can't really win any bonds here if you
play Bishop captures of course not comes
Bishop caps or it's not Queen but Bishop
captures and now Knight captures will
win a pawn but only briefly as f3 will
simply attack the pink piece and you
will lose this night as the rook will be
attacking the Queen of the Night Moves
so after rook F e1 we have Queen to c5
route 81 and now Queen to c4 now again
pressuring the pawn but now from c4 and
here we have Bishop to g5 offering a
trade of rooks
gelfand except we have rope captures
rook captures and now comes b5 here
gelfand is threatening before to kick
away the this night and then the Queen
will be undefended but also the knight
is regarding the a to pawn so we have f3
strengthening the center and it does
seem like Vincent just wandered a piece
but not really you can't move the knight
but you can move the Queen as the
elephants Queen and C 4 is also
undefended so we have Queen to e6 you
don't want to trade winds as you can
just move the Queen wait for Winston
Vincent to remove his knight and then
you will capture the a to pawn now which
is what happens Queen to a4 we have
Queen captures on a2 and now comes Queen
to c2 defending the knight and a 4 also
attacking the pawn on c6 and if the
Queen captures the pawn she will also be
guarding the knight from c6 so c5 here
by elephant so now the Queen cannot
capture because Queen captures night but
Knight can capture and here it's
interesting you can capture a pawn here
and it's very interesting why get funded
doesn't capture the pawn here because if
Queen captures Queen captures and Bishop
captures it seems grant has to pass
pawns to connect it passed pawns on the
Queen side and if a 5 so if a 4 a 5
comes
seems like it will be very very
difficult to stop these pawns and also
the bishop is covering a lot of the
important squares you need to pull the
pawn but here white would have knife to
a6 this comes with an attack against the
b4 pawn and after you defend it now
Bishop captures on f6 removes the
defender Bishop captures pawn captures
and after a5 seems like you still have a
very strong passed pawn and the bishop
is
covering the queening square but let's
say in 95 aking the bishop bishop has to
move and now comes this rook to be one
attacking the bishop roblox and now
comes Knight east 7 check King moves and
now Knight to c6 attacking the rook but
also the pawn on e5 rook attacks Knight
captures captures and ro K 2 and here
white will be able to draw this game as
the material on the board is completely
equal and it doesn't matter if it's the
outside passed pawn doesn't help you all
that much against a look
so after Knight captures on c5 gave from
the doesn't wanna win the pawn
immediately first rope the c8 pins the
knight on c5 rook to d2 now bringing
another defender to the b2 pawn and now
comes Queen to a5 the night is now
attacked so Bishop to e3 defending the
knight and c5 Queen to c7 now pinning
the night as the Queen and c2 would be
attacked twice if the knight moves but
to the Queen can move now
Queen to d3 we have Queen to c6 now
making room for the bishop so the bishop
can come to c7 about also aligning the
Queen with the King here King to f2 and
now comes Bishop to c7 as we've
mentioned Knights to a6 attacking the
pawn on b4 and also the bishop on c7 and
here it seems like the simple Bishop to
a5 would have been the best move here
simply defending the be for fun but
geffen played rook to d8 attacking I
haven't since Queen and it seemed gained
fund was probably considering something
like Queen e2 and then after rook
captures Bishop captures night to h5
pressuring the g3 pawn so now Knight
captures or Bishop captures isn't
possible because you have to do
something about this so after Knight
captures Queen captures now the queen is
also attacking in the g3 pawn f4 and now
you will not have time to capture on
before as Gelfand would have time to
push a5 this is most likely what gain
front was aiming for but after this rook
to the 8th move Vincent doesn't go for
this rather he simply plays Knight
captures on b4 and now you have a
problem
yes you can capture the Queen but your
queen is also under attack so let's see
what happens here if rook captures then
Queen captures on c6 and even with the
best idea which is bushel capture some
g3 you have to try and snatch a pawn and
if King captures then you can capture on
e3 but after Kingi to rook captures
Bishop that's or Akeem captures and
getting this pawn - oh I swear
for example a6 the material on the board
would be equal but the placement of
white pieces is better and Vincents King
is much more active so this would be a
much better position for Vincent so here
this was the first move that gelfand the
mist this Knight captures on b4 and he
decided to move the Queen we have Queen
to e6 and now again a Vincent it doesn't
move his Queen he could have moved it
simple to Queen to c3 but rather he
decides to capture on d8 Queen captures
on d8 so giving up the Queen for a rook
and the bishop Bishop captures rook
captures we have King to g7 and now
Bishop to d4 attacking pinning the night
here basically and offering the h3 pawn
now it's very interesting can you
capture the h3 pawn if you capture the
pawn then you get rook to d6 and you
can't get out of this pin and after you
suffer from a lot of checks for example
King bee - Queen G - checking c3 Queen
captures on f3 king c4 Queen captures on
e4 rook captures on f6 will come and
after one more check Knights to d3 will
block you will have to get out of any
discoveries but what I will again have a
much better position with a rope a
bishop and the night for a queen will
wide be able to win this it's hard to
say but yeah it will mostly be black who
will be suffering here so after Bishop
to d4 Gelfand isn't all that eager to
give up one more piece so King to h6 he
simply on pin and pins but now the king
is quite oddly placed there vincent
plays g4 and here we have an amazing
moment here if you put this exact same
position for example I tried it on stock
fish 9 with the depth of 21
which will tell you that night the d7 is
the absolute best move and the
disposition is a draw and it's very
interesting this is the exact move that
get one plate this night will come to e5
at some point block this bishops control
of g7 and perhaps the black will be able
to hold this but then it becomes even
more interesting when you put a
disposition after this one move has been
played on that same stop which nine
would depth twenty-one then he will tell
you white is winning so engines are
weird but you know even though he gave
and displayed the absolute best move
considered by the engine it was not
enough Knight to d5 here was played by
Vincent here we have f5 and now feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the move that wins this game for
white it's not an easy move but I'm sure
I'm sure you you know it's Sunday you
have time feel free to pause the video
and try to find it I'll give you a
couple of seconds as usual so for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just found a
truly an amazing move and for those of
you who just want to enjoyed short the
rook the move
Vincent played is rook to h8 now it's
very interesting why Rock to h8 is the
only move that wins here
well because whatever black plays he
will lose this game for example what's
the idea behind 95 if you simply block
this Bishop so the king can come back
into the game now Vincent's idea was g5
g5 is an absolute brilliant move because
now if King to h5 you simply get rook
captures and now after King captures you
will get f4 and this is checkmate
because the knight is covering f4 and
also f6 so the King has nowhere to go
this point is covering g4 and the rook
is covering well the entire H file so
this will be checkmate
and after g5 if you don't move the King
to h5 if you capture it immediately it
doesn't really matter
simply Bishop to e3 check f4 and now
comes the Bishop captures on f4 King age
4 and the rook captures on h7 this will
again be checkmate and lastly but not
leastly of course g5 like we've said
King g7 now because with 95 you have
blocked the bishop here
rook to e8 threatening to capture on a7
as the bishop is guarding a7 and white
has no moves here sorry black has no
moves here there's really nothing to do
with the king the the pawn the g5 bone
is not blocking any escape routes from
the king the knight on e5 is pinned and
you can only move the Queen but we're
gonna move the Queen to so it's like a
king to f7 now comes rook captures an a7
pink to e8 if you clicking to 8 then
Knights the c7 check wins the Queen as
it's check and the Queen is forked and
if you don't if you block for example
when I discerned and simply nice to f6
you attack the pin piece and black is
falling apart you have no moves Queen b3
rook captures King e6 captures captures
and now Bishop to c3 white it defends
everything and again nothing to do here
white is completely winning so after
this rook to h8 you don't have all that
many moves you can play a Giffen stride
F captures on e4 trying to destroy this
huge bone formation vincent created on
the kingside what Vincent doesn't mind
f4 a beautiful move that offers a knight
here but you can't capture it if you
capture the knight then you get the g5
check King moves and rook captures on h7
with checkmate so or you can capture
with the Queen and g5 but that's pretty
pointless
so after f4 we have nice - f8 a very
nice smooth that will defend the h7
point if needed in crucial moments and
also if Luke captures and Queen captures
now now it's actually black that's
better because there's nothing all that
impressive to do here g5 king will be
able to escape the rook is no longer
attacking the h7 pawn so not not
something you want to do so after night
to f8 now comes g5 oh this is this is
what check the g7 is covered by the
bishop you have to go down we have King
- h5 and now comes the excellent Knight
f6 check the king is in check has to
move the knight also attacks the h7
point so you all know what's coming next
King to h4 and now Knight captures on h7
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries or if Knight characters then
rogue captors will be checkmate
so here III was played by girlfriend but
after Bishop captures on III he in this
position decided to resign the game
because now there is really nothing to
do here
discoveries are coming of course if
Knight captures rook captures will be
checkmated you there's nothing to do
here
Seiya same as if you capture what the
King for example King King captures here
will be met with Knight to f6 check the
King has nowhere to go the night from f6
is guarding the g4 squares you cannot
escape you have to give up the night and
again this will be checkmate and
anything other than that you can simply
try giving up pieces for for no reason
but all of that will again be met with
checkmate so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and also we do have a
very excellent photo captured of the
moment after this game
it's a photo by Amar'e Emiliano also
official photographer of chess calm the
moment were Peter like oh who is a young
Vincent's coach congratulated him on his
victory over the legend Boris Gelfand so
you can really see
I mean elect aleko is a an elite chess
player himself so it it makes sense that
Vincent is becoming so strong if Flacco
is tutoring him so I've also put a link
to Marius to a Twitter page and a lot of
her other social media so you can follow
her as well and I did prepare the
standings after round 8 of the iron
chest 2018 so here we have it with six
and a half points only two players
rather avoid a shaky undercut in a dish
then we have four players with six
points maxime beaugeois Grove one how
Gawain Jones and Jeffries young and then
a whole lot of players would five and a
half points onigiri Vladimir Kramnik
Vishwanathan analogues and early shigeko
Nakamura
setting a correct in Richard report
Michael Adams we did gujarati
Artemia Vladislav Pavel Yan of Peter
Leko
say to Roman Baths Quran Audubon and a
lot of others and all the way down you
can see that 11 other iranian and the
Weslie so have only 5 points so a lot of
a lot of very
very strong elite chess players were not
able to get it all the way to the top
but there's still one more round to go a
lot of things can happen we're gonna get
back to that as well
I would also like to thank Jay Eric
Bobby treat VESA valkaama a software
engineer and veteran or zealots for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
a lot of useful links will be in the
description below such as add there will
be a nice article from chess 24 about
vincent gamers who do check that out as
well and if you haven't do check out my
video again on vincent game cameras
victory over richard report in the
gringa chess festival so as usual you
can check - on my previous videos your
thing call for watching and i'll see you
soon hopefully with some more
interesting content soon